you kind of were very public about how
you tried to get back together with her
you ended up on stage do you feel like
that was something that you regret or do
you awkward it's so cute and adorable at
the same time it is you know you're
nervous if you have to reach for the
water yeah that was Ellen DeGeneres
putting offset in the hot seat on her
show but he played it totally cool I
love my wife solar serious not a gaming
offset was serious getting candid about
winning back his wife after she broke up
with him last year amid cheating
allegations and we got a lot of love for
each other but things just haven't been
working out between us for a long time
and it's nobody's fault
it's just like I guess we grew out of
love that Instagram had us totally
shocked but just days later offsets
stormed the stage during her headlining
rolling loud set to ask for her
forgiveness
we have schedules and we have shows and
I just felt like if I gave a break
between time I just can't give that
break between time so it's my forefront
I step to it as a man and say I'm wrong
I step towards man and you don't have to
take me back but I just want you to know
I love you and I care this is and I'm
putting it all on the table I kind of
feel a whole new way about offset after
this me too you know I was almost crying
and I she's not laughing right now he
also says he wasn't the least bit
embarrassed even though he did get some
heat from fans hot am i fishing for you
that's all just me being vulnerable like
this you know any kind of it kind of it
kind of beat me with the response of
people but that's why our men don't be
trying to be vulnerable
yeah cuz when you do it it's like ah
it's something wrong with it anyway just
last month cardi actually talked to et
about working things out with her hubby
working it out yeah taking this loan
yeah we can see the family back together
me we always gonna be a family that's
together yeah my baby love us both and
we just wanna you know it's like like
having a baby that like the whole world
wants to see and watch and no you just
have to be very overly protective that's
what we kind of knew like these two are
meant to be either getting back together
she's giving him another shot but you
guys back in November she told us she
wanted more babies with him and praised
his fatherhood skills what is offset
like as a dad I mean is he changing
diapers he is changing diapers but like
I've been seeing offset being a dad he
already has three kids so I already fell
in love the way that he was a dad
already I'm like oh my god I could have
a little one with this guy he's really
good he's really good
is she more of a daddy's girl or a
Mama's girl do you think
more of me you naughty she loves me I
love the more bad things she's just
loyal to whoever gives her the milk yeah
guys want more are you talking about
that yeah I totally want more how many
more I want some more these two are
seriously the cutest I love them and you
guys love isn't perfect but they do seem
to fight for their relationship and I am
digging that team offset and Cardiacs be
all the way of course we will keep you
up-to-date on all the latest cardi and
offset news so be sure to subscribe to
all things et until next time I'm Katie
crafts and I'm Holly Stevens
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]